j'appuie assez fort Gary ou
parfait il y avaitil une zone en
particulier dont vous vouliez que je
m'occupe
aujourd'hui Gary avec combien de mecs tu
as déjà fait ça tu es le premier mec
avec qui j'ai une intimité j'ai eu une
femme elle est partie ça va bien se
passer c'est une Prom Prom la moitié
d'une promesse tu viendrais pas de
l'inventer ça tu as vraiment tout à
apprendre
toi ça fait bientôt 50 ans que je suis
enve en fait je n'ai absolument pas vécu
Gary je vais m'occuper de toi on va
trouver quelqu'un rien que pour toi la
vache il y en a plein qui sont canon je
crois que ça fait un peu trop pour moi
trop tard le mec est en chemin attends
quoi salut ça va Bro je vais juste
rentrer et sortir oh commence par
rentrer très classe comme atterrissage
qu'est-ce que tu fais j'appelle les
secours Gary c'était un accident c'était
ta première expérience c'est normal on
fait tous des erreurs il a saigné à
travers la bâche c'est un parquet en
freine brute il est hyper poreux oh mais
tu es tellement gay non purée vous êtes
de la police non attendez et vous non
cool parce que le Dark web est basé sur
la
confiance c'est vraiment ça que ça fait
c'est vraiment ça que ça fait je suis un
popers humain je dilate j'assoupliis je
suis très content de t'avoir
rencontré même si ça a provoqué la mort
de pas mal de
[Musique]
je
les grenouilles de ont l'habitude de
sagenouiller maisù estce que vous
allez je suis bandant et h je suis
un- que vous
l' j
juste l
profile